das war eine riesige enttäuschung ende
februar denn das messgerät hp 3 mit dem
spitznamen maulwurf war stecken
geblieben statt der angepeilten 5 meter
hatte sich die sonne nur 30 zentimeter
in den boden bohren beziehungsweise
hämmern können seit ende februar dürfte
den forschungsteams aus deutschland
zusammen mit der nasa daran den maulwurf
wieder zum laufen zu bringen gibt es
eine chance kriegt um science fiction
die gibt's täglich faszinierendes seines
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
der mars maulwurf p3 ist im marsboden
steckengebliebenen katastrophale
nachricht nichts geht mehr eben boden
der ebene elysium planie zärtlich des
äquators und zwar kurz nach dem start
das hämmern war quasi gerade erst
losgegangen die rede ist von der
raumsonde des deutschen zentrums für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr mit der
bezeichnung hp 3 keat flow and physical
properties package erstmalig in der
geschichte der raumfahrt soll sich die
sonde bis zu fünf meter tief in den
boden bohren und die wärme und
temperatur leitfähigkeit des untergrund
materials messen rund vier stunden dient
der roboter bei seiner ersten etappe am
28 februar dieses jahres 2009 10 durch
4000 hammerschläge waren es wohl und
zwar angetrieben durch einen
vollautomatischen und elektrisch
angetriebenen hammerschlag mechanismus
ein flach kabel das mit allerlei mesz
sensorik ausgestattet ist zieht der mars
maulwurf dabei hinter sich mit in den
boden doch plötzlich ging es nicht mehr
weiter und der maulwurf kippte leicht um
etwa 15 grad die vermutung er ist auf
ein hindernis im untergrund gestoßen
seitdem sitzt ap drei also fest dabei
waren bis zu fünf meter tiefe angepeilt
damit er überhaupt eine chance bekommt
den wärmefluss aus dem inneren des mars
liegt er jetzt zu erkunden seitdem haben
forschungsteams des dlr zusammen mit
fachleuten der nasa verschiedene
versuche unternommen den maulwurf wieder
zum laufen oder besser gesagt zum graben
zu kriegen leider ohne erfolg doch der
maulwurf soll auf jeden fall gerettet
werden und so hatten sich die teams dazu
entschieden eine umfassende
rettungsaktion zu starten deswegen haben
sie sich in den vergangenen monaten
durch spezielle
dann kisten hier auf der erde gegraben
und somit eben hier auf der erde
getestet was den maulwurf auf den mars
wohl zum stoppen brachte außerdem
sollten die szenarien zeigen wie man den
mars maulwurf möglicherweise doch noch
dazu bringen könnte sich wie ein selbst
ein schlagender nagel weiter einzugraben
was ist mit dem grabensystem los und
warum dringt es nicht weiter in den
boden ein die forschungsteams sind
mittlerweile davon überzeugt dass die
geringe reibung im staubigen material an
der mars oberfläche ein großes problem
darstellt dazu der dlr-forscher tilman
spohn aus berlin wir sehen uns
mittlerweile ziemlich sicher dass dem
auto für mangelnde halt im boden zu
schaffen macht möglicherweise springt er
deswegen in seinem loch nur auf und ab
anstatt sich in den boden einzugraben
zudem haben sich höchstwahrscheinlich
auch hohlräume zwischen dem boden und
dem maulwurf gebildet diese probleme
sollen jetzt laut rettungsplan mit hilfe
des roboterarms der nasa mars sonde
inside boden werden diese war ende
november 2008 10 auf dem roten planeten
gelandet und habe drei gehört zu er
der roboterarm soll die stütz struktur
die jetzt noch auf dem maulwurf sitzt
entfernen und zwar über kommandos die
noch in diesem monat also im juni 2009
10 in drei paketen zur sonne geschickt
werden soll jeder schritt soll so von
den forschungsteams im detail
nachvollzogen werden können so erhoffen
sich die fachleute endlich zu verstehen
wie es dem maulwurf geht und wo die
genauen probleme liegen der insight
roboterarm soll jedoch nicht nur die
struktur entfernt sondern auch das
weitere hämmern unterstützen und zwar
indem er für zusätzlichen druck sorgt
dazu tillmann spuren durch die
zusätzliche last erhöht sich der druck
auf den maulwurf und damit die reibung
an seiner außenwand das alles klingt
viel einfacher als es ist denn im worst
case könnte es passieren dass der
roboterarm den maulwurf aus versehen aus
dem boden zieht mit fatalen folgen denn
dann wäre es unmöglich das gerät wieder
zurück ins loch zu manövrieren nur
hoffen kann man zudem auch dass der
maulwurf im untergrund nicht auf einen
dicken stein gestoßen ist was ja bisher
die vermutung auch war
denn daran würde er keinesfalls vorbei
kommen und damit vollends scheitern
auf dem mars beweist durch diese fotos
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar raumzeit wirkt der zukunft bis dann
bleibt dran